on behalf of the Euros Space Program
189 days into your solo Journey
Commander
pratka how are you
[Music]
feeling what I'm doing is for everyone
back home and that makes me very
proud and your wife Lena of
course I'm sure she's looking forward to
having your home safe and sound
[Music]
he's not doing well he misses his
wife and he shouldn't have
left 6 months in isolation you start
thinking too
much I'm getting
interference I did not intend to
frighten you skinny
human do not be afraid
afraid I'm losing my
mind you wish to know if I am
real I am like you an
Explorer your
loneliness intrigued me why are you here
I might be of help I wish to assist you
in your emotional
distress I don't need your help
but you
do you go where I go and I go where you
go right Spaceman these are your
thoughts I am simply finding them with
[Music]
you everything that begins must end I'm
not allowing
that you go where I go and I go where
you
[Music]
go I just want to come
home